COMPANY COMPANIES ACTIVIST TURN
TO AN END TOMORROW, GUTFELD IS
NEXT.
>> HAPPY HUMP DAY, AMERICA VERY
SUMMER IS JUST AROUND THE CORNER
.
SMELL THE LOTION IN THE FEAR.
AT TWITTER HEADQUARTERS,
CASUALTIES ARE MOUNTING, THERE'
PAINTING, AND THAT WAS JUST A
JANITOR UNCLOGGING THE MEN'S
ROOM TOILET IT WAS A DESERVED
JAB DIRECTED AT TWITTER'S LEGAL
TEETH, I HOPE I GOT THAT RIGHT
IT IS FUN TO SAY THOUGH.
THAT RIGHT AFTER HE BOUGHT THE
COMPANY HE GOT CALLED A VIRTUAL
MEETING OR IF YOU'RE JEFFREY
TOOBIN, THAT WOULD BE CREAM.
I SWORE I WOULDN'T DO MORE OF
THOSE JOKES, BUT I LIED RIGHT
SOMETIMES SHE IS SEEN AS THE
COMPANY'S MORAL AUTHORITY LIKE
AM HERE AT FOX.
NOW, HE IS SCARED BECAUSE
MUSKETS CALLED FOR TWITTER TO
EMBRACE FREE-SPEECH COME UP
ADVOCATING TWITTER'S ALGORITHM
WHILE SUGGESTING ONLY CONTENT
AND REQUIRED BY LAW.
ONLY WHEN CERTAIN VOICES TO BE
HEARD AND LABELS OTHERS AS HEAT
SPEECH PERMITS INFORMATION VERY
CHEESY SENSOR AND ONE WITH HER
THUMB ON THE SCALE OR INTRODUCE
CASE, OR TWO LEFT FEET.
ACCORDING TO POLITICAL COVER AN
THE MEETING SHE CRIED UNDER THE
UNCERTAINTY GET COME.
IS THAT REALLY WHY SHE CRIED?
I'M NOT SURE SURE.
I'M AN EXPERT ON MAKING WOMEN
CRY.
IT'S JUST A REACTION THEY HAVE
HELP WHEN THEY SEE ME IN PERSON.
>> THE NEW OF LATE-NIGHT TALK,
GREG GUTFELD.
CAKE EIGHT THEY NEVER HAVE ME.
HE HAS MADE OVER $70 MILLION AS
THE SENSOR INCLUDING 7 MILLION
IN 2020, THAT'S MORE THAN I MAD
LAST YEAR WORKING HERE AND RUN
MOONLIGHTING AS A.
HER SALARY DOUBLED, 2021.
THE MEDIA ACTS LIKE SHE IS A
VULNERABLE UNDERLING BULLIED BY
MANIACAL TYRANTS.
SHE'S CRYING BECAUSE SHE KNOWS
HER LOSS OF POWER MEANS OR LOSS
OF FUTURE MILLIONS.
THE MEDIA CONTINUES TO GO
BONKERS, CUE THE FREAK SPREAD
GET THE RIGHT HAS ALREADY SEIZE
AS THIS GROUND THAT THEY ARE
UNDECIDED FREE-SPEECH GRADE
THEREFORE THE.
>> ELON MUSK, HE MISSES THE OLD
SELF ADVOCATE AND THE 80s
GOING TO WANT THAT BACK.
HE GET THERE HE IS GREAT WHEN
YOU HAVE NO ARGUMENT, CALLED
PEOPLE ARE RACIST.
AND ANYBODY WHO TRIES TO DEFEND
THE CHARGE.
IT EXPLAINS THE MSNBC REFUSAL T
CAN THIS NOT BRAG COME OF THE
GREAT WORK, THEY FIRED HER SHE
WILL FIRE THEM FOR RACISM BUT
WITH THE RATINGS, THAT SUIT
WOULD BE THROWN OUT LIKE IT WAS
WORN BY, BUT AS MUSK IS SHOWING
COME OF THIS MIRROR IS CRUMBLIN
OVER ITS OWN HYSTERIA.
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP ALL HE
HEARD ABOUT WAS MCCARTHYISM.
HE WAS AN EVIL SENATOR WHO LOST
A WITCH HUNT FOR UNDERCOVER
COMMUNIST WHO HAD INFILTRATED
THE GOVERNMENT SPREAD THIS IS
THE MID- 1950s WHEN IT CLEAR
MIGHT NOT OF BEEN TRUE.
ULTIMATELY THIS MERE TACTICS LE
TO HIS DOWNFALL.
HE ALSO HARMED THE ANTI-
COMMUNISM MOVEMENTS.
BERNIE SANDERS FOR SHORT.
NOW WHENEVER HOLLYWOOD OR THE
MEDIA TRIES TO PLAY HERO OR
VICTIM THEY PLAY THE MCCARTHYIS
CARD, HOW BRAVE THEY WERE TO
STAND UP TO THE FEAR MONGERING.
TODAY IT'S ALL DIFFERENT.
THE ACTUAL OPPRESSION TODAY IS
ALMOST ENTIRELY DONE BY
LEFT-WINGERS USING A CAMPAIGN
THAT SPREADS FEAR OF ALLEGED
RACIST OR HOMOPHOBIC INFLUENCE
ON AMERICAN INSTITUTIONS.
THE USE MOTION AND DEALINGS TO
MANIPULATE YOU.
IT'S PART OF THE BIG FLIP, THE
FREEZE FEATURES ARE NO LONGER O
THE LEFT, BUT ON THE RIGHT, THE
PRO- WOMEN'S MOVEMENT IS NO
LONGER ON THE LEFT FOOT ON THE
RIGHT.
THESE DAYS THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO SAVE WOMEN SPORTS ARE
TALK ABOUT STRANGE BEDFELLOWS,
THE BIG FLIP IS ALSO HAPPENING
IN ENTERTAINMENT PEERED BACK IN
THE 80s IT WAS THE RIGHT WHO
SAID ROCK MUSIC TURNS KIDS INTO
SATANISTS OR WORSE DEMOCRATS,
NOW IT'S THE RIGHT FIGHTING FOR
COMEDIANS TO SAY WHAT THEY WANT
AND IT'S THE LEFT ACTING AS
SENSORS CLAIMING THAT WORDS ARE
WEAPONS.
PRETTY SOON THE TSA WON'T LET
YOU BOARD WITHOUT THE RIGHT
PRONOUNS.
THE LEFT HAS TURNED EVERYTHING
THEY CLAIM TO HATE AND THEN SOME
.
YES, THEY ARE JOE McCARTHY.
IT'S LIKE THEY HAD A FREEWAY AN
PRODUCED KEITH OLBERMANN.
THE OTHER SIDE, ELON MUSK IS NO
OUR THOMAS JEFFERSON, THE FATHE
OF FREE-SPEECH GRADE THE BABYLO
BEES ARE NEW NEW YORK TIMES,
JOAN ROGAN IS OUR CNN, AND TYRUS
, HE IS OUR WALTER CRONKITE
WITH MORE TATTOOS THAN AN MS 13
GANG MEMBER.
I AM SHARING THE FUN AND THE
RISK WITH YOU, BUT WHATEVER I A
YOU CAN BE SURE AND PROBABLY
GOING TO BE CALLED A RACIST
TRANS PHOBIC EXIST WHICH THINGS
TO THE LEFT DOESN'T MEAN SLEEP.
>> SHE HAS HANDLED MORE SCOOPS
THAN AN OCTOPUS AT
BASKIN-ROBBINS, OLIVIA MOYNAHAN.
HIS STYLIST HAS A SEEING-EYE DOG
.
FOX ACROSS AMERICA HOST.
HER PEDIATRICIAN ONCE SAID IT
WAS FULL OF LIFE BEFORE HE
SLIPPED OUT THE LIFEBOAT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
LAST DOCTOR WHO TEXT IS.
THE NWA WORLD TELEVISION
CHAMPION, TYRUS.
>> STILL NUMBER ONE?
>> STILL NUMBER ONE.
THERE WAS LOTS OF MASERATI TAKA
RADKE WHEN I SAY MASERATI YOU
DIDN'T HEAR ME AND SAY THAT'S
CODE FOR SNOWCONE AND YOU GUYS
WE'RE TALKING OVER THAT.
>> THAT WAS IN THE ROOM, YOU
SPECIFICALLY SAID IN THE ROOM.
AGI WOULD STAKE MY LIFE ON IT,
TYRUS.
YOU KNOW WHAT SNOWCONE IS FOR?
I CAN'T TELL YOU.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR SNOWCONE DAY
EITHER.
WELCOME TO THE CELL.
>> THAT MAKES ONE OF US.
THAT WAS SUCH AN AD WASN'T
PHRASE.
>> YOU DELIVERED IT VERY WELL
GREAT.
>> YOU GET A LOT OF BUSINESS
GROUPS, TELL US SOMETHING WE
MIGHT NOT KNOW ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE TRASHING
ELON MUSK ON THEIR INTERNAL
E-MAILS FOR IT WHAT'S IT CALLED/
?
>> 'S LACK.
>> THAT SHOWS HOW MUCH I KNOW.
>> THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
COMING OUT IN THE COMING DAYS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THIS WHOLE
OVERREACTION TO ELON MUSK BUYIN
TWITTER.
IT WOULD THINK THAT WAY PEOPLE
ARE SHOCKED WAS THAT TWITTER WA
SHANGRI-LA WHERE THERE WAS
ELEVATED DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HUMA
FLOURISHING
THE REALITY THAT TWITTER IS A
TOXIC CESSPOOL WHERE PEOPLE TEL
YOU THAT YOU LOOK LIKE YOUR FAC
GOT HIT BY A SHOVEL AND THEY
HOPE YOU DIE.
>> I WAS KIDDING.
>> FOR YOU THE ONE WHO ASKED TO
START COCAINE UP THERE.
AT ALL MAKES SENSE NOW.
>> I DON'T SNORT COKE OFTEN.
>> A HUMBLE BREAK.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IT CAN GET
WORSE THAN IT ALREADY HAS.
JUST PUT THE ALGORITHM ONLINE
AND THERE IS TRANSPARENCY.
I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW WHY DONALD
TRUMP IS NOT ALLOWED ON TWIN
SPEAK TO TWITTER BUT THE
AYATOLLAH KHOMEINI IS.
IT CAN'T GET WORSE THAN IT IS.
ELON MUSK HAVE A LOT OF IDEAS A
A VISIONARY.
>> WELL, JIMMY, WHY ARE THEY SO
SCARED.
WHY ARE THEY SO SCARED OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
IT IS LIKE YOUR JACKET TO A
QUARTER.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WOULD LIKE MY
SHOES.
THEY ARE A TRIBUTE TO THE YELLO
BRICK ROAD AND YOU TELL DOROTHY
TO FOLLOW WHEN THE WIZARD OF OZ.
THIS IS A SHOUT OUT TO YOU KING
OF LATE-NIGHT.
FOR A BUNCH OF PEOPLE WHO SWORE
THAT TWITTER DIDN'T FAVOR THEM,
THEY ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
CHANGE OF MANAGEMENT.
>> SENT TO THE BRILLIANT POINT
ABOUT, OH, THIS SITE THAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE.
TWITTER IS A FIGHT CLUB FOR
PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT TO GET HIT
.
YOU GO ON AND AS A CONFRONTATIO
WAITING FOR YOU AND HE'S NOT
GOING TO CENSOR ANYTHING FOR TH
MOST PART.
IT WOULD DEFEAT THE WHOLE POINT
OF TWITTER.
IT IS INCENTIVIZED CONFLICT BUT
EVERYBODY IS TELLING YOU DO I
READ AND IT'S ELON MUSK AND THA
THE WORST KIND OF FREE SPEECH.
HE'S THE MOST HOMOPHOBIC THINGS
WE'VE EVER HEARD WE WERE TOLD
THE FBI IS LOOKING INTO THIS.
THIS IS A REALLY LONG
INVESTIGATION SINCE 2017.
WHAT THE RIGHT SEES, HE HAS NOT
SAYING NO ONE CAN DO WHAT THEY
WANT ON THE LEFT.
MASK MANDATES ARE ENDING BUT YO
CAN'T WEAR A MASK.
YOU CAN DO WITH EPIC YOU WANT.
I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS BUT
THE TRUTH IS THIS IS WHY THEY
ARE OVER PROTESTING IS BECAUSE
THEY LOST THAT KEY CENSORSHIP.
IT ALWAYS WENT THEIR WAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
WORSE DISINFORMATION THAN
WEAPONS OF MASS DISTRACTION.
LET'S GO TO WAR AND KILLED TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND SPEN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THEY HAVE WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
>> TYRUS, I FEEL LIKE WE'VE GOT
A FUN, I SET THIS ON THE FIVE,
FUN PRE-ELECTION.
WE WON SOMETHING THIS WEEK AND
KIND OF FUN TO WATCH THE PEOPLE
WHO LIKE IT SO MUCH BREAKDOWN I
PUBLIC.
>> IT IS KIND OF LIKE THE GUY
WHO WAS ASSISTANT TO THE
ASSISTANT.
HE'S REMINDED THAT THEY DO NOT
EXIST.
SO WE BASICALLY HAVE DWIGHT
HAVING A TEMPER TANTRUM OVER
TWITTER AND WE ARE ALL JAMMED.
THAT IS THE OFFICE REPRESENTING
--
SPEE-03 PART OF THAT SHOW?
SUSPECTS THE OFFICE.
>> IT'S NEVER ON.
>> NO ONE THE MORE ELON MUSK
SAYS LESS, BECAUSE HE HASN'T
SAID ANYTHING YET.
HE HASN'T COME OUT OF THE PULPI
AND STARTED SAYING THE FOLLOWIN
PEOPLE ARE DANCING TWITTER AND
WELCOME BACK AND KNEES HAVING A
EVIL AWARD ANKLET DINNER FOR
ANYONE, LIKE WELCOME BACK AND W
ARE HAVING ALL KINDS OF FAKE
REFILLS ON TWITTER'S AND ALL
THESE GENIUSES THAT ARE BACK.
WHAT A GREAT IDEA.
CHANGED TO A CONFEDERATE FLAG.
IT'S COMING OUT.
AND IT BRINGS OUT THE ABSOLUTE
WORST IN PEOPLE.
HER COMMENT ABOUT APARTHEID, HE
FOR 17 YEARS OLD WHEN HE LEFT
SOUTH AFRICA.
I DON'T KNOW MUCH OF A POLITICA
MOVER AND SHAKER HE WAS.
I GET IS AN OVERT SHAPER BUT I
DON'T THINK HE WAS DOING A LOT
AND HE LEFT, WHICH IS A GOOD
SIGN WHEN YOU LEAVE THE COUNTRY
THAT YOU'RE NOT REALLY DEALING
WITH WHAT IS GOING ON.
THAT'S ONE OF THE WORST THING
THAT I'VE HEARD THAT WAS
PERVERSE IN ANY WAY.
IF YOU WOULD'VE SAID THAT ABOUT
ANYBODY ELSE, I WOULD NOT BE
HERE ANYMORE.
I'VE TRIED TO SAY THINGS.
AND IF THERE'S EVER A REASON TO
CANCEL SOMEBODY, APARTHEID WAS
HORRIBLE MOMENT IN HISTORY, IN
THE WORLD.
AND YOU ARE EXCUSING --
YOU ARE ACCUSING SOMEBODY OF
THAT SPEE-03 IT MAKES NO SENSE
AT ALL, KAT.
WHAT IS IN YOUR BRAIN RIGHT NOW
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
PUBLICLY IN FRONT OF MILLIONS.
I ALWAYS FORGET ABOUT THE SECON
PART.
I THINK IT IS GREAT BECAUSE I'V
GOTTEN SO MANY MORE NEW POLYMERS
.
YOU THINK THAT FAKE THING IT'S
MAKING ME LOOK BETTER IS
SOMETHING BELOW ME?
LOOK AT ME.
I'M IN THE PROCESS OF GETTING
READY FOR A FOURSOME THAT'S
IDENTICAL TO THAT OF A DRAG
QUEEN.
THEY CARE AND PAY CLASHES WHERE
THE EXACT SAME KIND OF BROUGHT
SO AS LONG AS I'M LOOKING GOOD,
I'M GOING TO SAY IT IS A PLAN.
SO YOU LOOK ALMOST LIKE IT'S
COSMETIC.
EXPECTS IT IT'S COSMETIC KID
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT IT IS.
>> I GAVE THOUSANDS OF FOLLOWERS
.
THEY ARE ALL REAL AND THEY ARE
YOUNG BEAUTIFUL.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN.
WE'VE GOT TO MOVE ON.
UP NEXT, SHOULD STUDENT LOAN